but we wanted to re-emphasize what  sherry mentioned a tweet from the Nevada  Department of Transportation along with  the Nevada Highway Patrol and Metro  Police please do not try to escape the  heat by going up to Mount Charleston  there's just not enough parking on  either Kyle Canyon Road or Lee Canyon  Road if at the Nevada Department of  Transportation put out a tweet that  included this photograph of one of the  overhead signs access to the Mount  Charleston roads is for people who live  there otherwise it just gets too crowded  and they will turn people away and if  you are parking in places where you're  not supposed to you could even get a  ticket so again you want to get out of  the heat we understand that maybe go up  there and just turn right back around  because the temperature drops as you're  heading up Kyle Canyon and Lee Canyon  roads Alex